c'est un nouveau départ pour mohammad sa
femme et leurs deux fils de 18 et 21 ans
ils sont arrivés d'afghanistan le 11 ou
à toronto radio canada acceptent de ne
pas dévoiler son nom complet pour des
raisons de sécurité
sun c'était très occupé pendant la
quarantaine dit il on avait des rendez
vous sur zoom pour nous expliquer
comment allait se passer notre
installation les papiers administratifs
à remplir notre numéro d'assurance
sociale comment nous déplacer
après sa quarantaine il a choisi de
s'installer à thunder bay car c'est ici
que vit son ami et ancien patron comme
mohammad quelques 500 afghans ont déjà
été relogées dans des collectivités
ontariennes selon ottawa et sont prêts à
commencer une nouvelle vie
on a reçu notre résidence permanente on
prend des cours d'anglais à landon 36
afghans ont été accueillis dans la
communauté ce sont des gens qui ont
travaillé pour l'ambassade du canada au
comme des interprètes pour des les
forces armées se sont déjà prêts à
intégrer le milieu de travail et c'est
le défi qui attend ces nouveaux
arrivants trouver un logement un travail
mais aussi surmonter leurs traumatismes
j'ai perdu mon plus jeune fils mon père
un cousin au total six membres de ma
famille sont morts lorsque les talibans
ont attaqué ma maison raconte mort hamad
qui vivait dans un village de la
province de kandahar le soutien mental
est vital rapporte aussi nourri à cam
ranh avec son organisme enfants sans
frontières elle apporte vêtements jouets
et produits essentiels à quelque 350
afghan en quarantaine près de toronto
parmi eux de nombreux enfants parfois
orphelins
hier un enfant de 6 ans en détresse
psychologique a été envoyé à l'hôpital
raconte elle
ils sont traumatisés mais ont de
l'espoir selon elle un espoirs et des
rêves qu'on peut lire dans le regard et
les mots de mohammad
nous sommes prêts à étudier fort et
travailler pour que nos rêves se
réalisent dans notre nouveau pays ici
cammy fei raizen radio canada toronto